I've heard Pedro Pascal talk I'm your
daddy and I've heard Joel Miller talk
when she tried to get some sleep what
did you define the voice in The Last of
Us because this isn't a voice I've ever
heard you use before there were so many
different resources that I was able to
use to to put everything together
there's a voice that's on the page that
uh Craig Mason and Neil druckman wrote
in these incredible episodes you have
equality from the game you've got a
quality that Troy brought to Joel that
is I think essential in the playing of
the character and you've got a costume
department and a makeup department and I
have a pair person who was all part of
like the look and sound of Joel and then
there was sort of what made sense to me
and the way I heard it and and what was
sounded um right I'm not family no your
cargo